the old Palace of Westminster burned to
the ground in 1834 without urgent
restoration it's feared a similar
disaster could befall its Victorian
replacement too but now the organization
set up in 2018 to manage the huge
renovation project has been scrapped
after estimating the bill would reach 7
billion pounds at least
I could weep for the five years we've
lost now we have no sponsor body no
plans to carry out the work and still
argument about whether we should stay in
the building while the work is done or
not this is not about us as MPS it's
about the building that belongs to the
country without full-scale restoration
the current bill just to keep the
building safe is two and a half million
pounds a week they're Around the Clock
fire patrols and work to repair
crumbling masonry is constantly underway
here in Saint Stephens Hall which had to
be rebuilt after the catastrophic fire
of 1834 work has been going on over the
past year to painstakingly restore the
Victorian ceiling but the real
renovation challenge is under our feet
we were refused access to film in the
basement but archive shows a Labyrinth
of gas and dripping water pipes threaded
alongside miles of electric wiring and a
Victorian sewage pumping system the site
is also riddled with asbestos
in 2018 Parliament voted to move out for
the project and set up an independent
sponsor body of experts and politicians
to lead it last year they published
estimates predicting the work would cost
between 7 and 13 billion pounds and take
up to 28 years if MPS Lords and staff
stayed put the bill could reach 22
billion and last as long as 76 years
it's ridiculous we can't have some
vastly expensive gold-plated plan
especially when the economy is in
tatters you don't need to move everybody
out but the experts argue that not
moving out will be more expensive more
disruptive more dangerous the MPS don't
mind having to move out for a time but
nobody wants to move out for some hugely
long period that we might never get back
MPS and Lords have now abolished the
sponsor body and brought the project
in-house meanwhile debate continues
about where they'd even move out to with
Millions spent on plans for venues in
London but ministers also suggesting
York or Stoke-on-Trent we just need to
crack on and do it and instead we Circle
background all the time and change
decisions there's been something like
over 50 fire incidents in the recent
decade and those any one of them could
have resulted in a kind of Notre Dame
style absolute burning down of the
palace Parliament told us members have
agreed to prioritize safety critical
work and they're getting on with plans
for the complex restoration and
developing a wide set of options but as
their Georgian predecessors discovered
if they delay the costs could get much
higher Amanda raycast Sky News
Westminster